[Music]
so the metaverse
we should start we should start the
first catholic church in the metaverse
okay
anyway someone's building
sci-fi haptic gloves um lets you feel vr
objects using air pockets this
i mean that's [ __ ] sick but that's
what i'm saying this is what it's this
is what dating is gonna be can you
imagine getting like fingering someone
with a haptic glove yeah that is so
depressing and you're gonna have some
like crazy automated fleshlight yeah you
know what i mean yeah like we're already
pretty close to that yeah like there's
dildos that you could probably you know
that are electronic hook up to some
crazy system flashlights
and then once you have these haptic
gloves and you can feel each other
that's just you can just have sex i mean
even with like remote control underwear
and all that [ __ ] i mean the concept is
already there it's like kind of
mainstream yeah i was actually i think
something that was interesting about
that tim ferriss podcast the thing that
i took away from it
was
um
what's the guy's name
which guy uh the one with chris dixon
and naval naval when naval brought up
the
the
switch to web 3 being kind of abrupt and
quick because
unlike web 2 web 3
is like anyone can just iterate on what
already exists so like and because
everything's community driven like it's
kind of forcing adoption to things
faster so rather than like a big company
coming up with a search engine and then
running like crypto.com running ads
getting celebrity endorsements all that
[ __ ] it's like it's all like these niche
pockets of concepts where it's like yo i
want to start a dow for like a racing
company and they build a community
around that and then that multiplies by
like you know 10 000 people and before
you know it you have like millions of
people
already utilizing like web 3 concepts
and everything is oh everything's owned
by everyone and everything's open source
yeah so it's like they have like uh
because they're directly tied to it and
it's all sort of like they
whether you're in the community or you
believe what this community is doing or
whatever
um
you're
you're also like invested in it
literally so
uh yeah i thought that was kind of
interesting so like metaverse and all
this [ __ ] it might just like pop off
like that yeah cause
yeah yeah i was talking to
someone this weekend we were talking
about people buying land
in uh decentraland
yeah apparently it's like 10 20 grand
and you can like buy which is like a
[ __ ] ton of money but like you can't
really buy anything for that in the real
world now no
and then and then i read like this
really depressing tweet from uh who is
it whitney webb she was a girl on tim
dillon's podcast talking about
um
jeffrey epstein and all that stuff yeah
yeah yeah
um
and she was kind of like this is how
they want you to think you'll never own
anything in the real world
i will only be and i was like damn
that's kind of real i had a really grim
brief talk with siva about this oh it's
like
that's no wonder the media's like yeah
this is the right thing metaverse let's
all you can afford stuff here let's all
and it's like because you because they
they don't want you to own anything in
the real world yeah they want to own the
real world yeah
and uh
what is this
this is a parcel of land in decentraland
and it's uh
6 000 mana which is 24k is that what
they use in decentraland mana yeah it's
the central lands specific uh coin buy
some of that but it's built off of
ethereum yeah that was like a dark
thought or the thing that steve and i
were talking about where
so he sent me a couple things one was
this presentation from 2018 where a dude
was demonstrating this really really
solid uh facial recognition
um
application for like 3d characters and
just an ar kit okay like what's embedded
and like the like the face like the
face angles or whatever it was just
using that a bike helmet like a 10 like
mount
um and then like a 40 webcam
and
he had like some rudimentary like haptic
gloves like for fingertips and stuff but
he had this fully like 3d baby that he
was like representing himself as in a 3d
space it was like this demon baby it
kind of looks like post malone's like
devil baby
he was like yeah so i'm you know i
basically want to show you that like
this um this concept is is not expensive
and it's like very near because i'm just
using unreal and i'm like i'm this
full-on like 3d character that can like
smile and emote and like be angry and
uh siva brought up that and then
uh
some like metaverse stuff and he's like
dude
everyone is just slowly being
conditioned to think of like being
inside
yeah
he's like you know oh you don't have to
leave like that's what it is like not
even like the ownership part it's just
like yeah you don't you don't have to
leave you can you can do that at home
you can watch a concert at home you can
you don't have to own anything yeah you
don't have to afford anything yeah
you don't need a real race car just get
a digital race car yeah
you don't need independence or yeah
it's because you can be free online
terminally online yeah i mean it sounds
kind of
also
right-wing conspiracy theory-esque sure
but i mean it's it's
i don't know i mean it's not totally
invalid it's maybe not as sinister as
like um the phrase of oh
they want you they don't want you to own
the real world like they meaning like
the powers that be
i think a more like
real world
like interpretation of that is like
companies like facebook and people who
are in this space it's in their interest
to promote these ideas
they're kind of like inherently doing
that by like
convincing you that you don't need the
real world because they have a product
right so that's all it is so yeah in in
that way i think that is true like they
have this product they want you to use
it they
see all these things that
they can offer you in the realm of like
the product um and in their mind like oh
yeah this is a good idea yeah what is
this
um
so this is a workout routine oh so he's
actually doing this in real life in real
life yeah he's like whoa that's so
realistic yeah he's got like a box all
the movements are like perfect oh my god
i cannot wait to play call of duty like
this if you don't think he's gonna be
too real what
playing like first person shooters like
this like that's this example he's
holding a gun doing the motions you do
during like a first-person shooter but
i feel like i think it would feel too
real that's i think what people want oh
man like if someone's like don't don't
shoot and kill him
i'm not like oh oh i mean like killing
other people
huh
you don't think so
i don't think it'll feel like that yet
like in a video game you're killing
characters it's like you know they move
like characters
everything's like that that when he just
like ducked behind the thing there
and i was like damn it felt like
paintball for a second yeah it's too
real i mean that's that's that is true
like to mentally who knows how the brain
will interpret something like that
that's what i'm saying yeah you see a
movement like that and you attribute
that as a human yeah and then you kill
the human yeah well it's a good thing uh
we're not there yet which seems like
we're pretty damn close
yeah it's a good thing we only have like
two years left before everyone's
desensitized to murder yeah and just but
here's the thing everyone will be stuck
inside so they won't try it in real life
exactly why murder be an ibrahimovic
real world exactly that's going to be
the sad part about vr is when we lose
all our ted bundy documentaries yeah
yeah they're yeah they'll be sad when we
lose serial killers yeah
culturally serial killers will be null
and void why did he choose this
like
weightlifting influencer dude if you're
this character in the metaverse are you
choosing anything other than being
ripped as [ __ ] i'm just like why the
nike shorts
and then you know what i'm saying dope
calves
i guess that [ __ ] that looks like he's
about to run a marathon tall and ripped
what transcends all mediums of existence
yeah can you imagine going to the
metaverse and choosing to be five nine
[Laughter]
i wanna let people know i'm humble
cool man i'm 6 12. i want to let my
voice shine yeah we don't care my
personality we just don't care it's
going to be wild when people
design their lives around like a room in
their house to be whatever they are in
the metaverse yeah well i'm a uh
i'm a potion merchant
in the wizard world
you imagine blowing up as a celebrity in
the metaverse how weird that would be
i want to be a girl
nice
i'm gonna be a hot ass model
envelope as a baddie
and go back out in the real world as
regular as me
i'm gonna be a peloton instructor yeah
that's it yeah
we should yeah
we should be a woman duo in the
metaverse that are peloton instructors
super positive yeah really inspiring
super in shape yeah
yeah and then we get to the real world
and
we do it we do a irl meet and greet
everyone's like wait
no it's just all guys yeah
oh man what the [ __ ]
i'm excited though
i want this second life dude
i know that honestly sounds kind of fun
you know be tight